- How would the throuple work
if one of you would want to break up
with another person in the
party, but not the third?
- She's starting drama.
- I'm just curious.
- Get a lawyer.
- Oh no!
(laughs)
- [Producer] If you were alone in a room
with a throuple who are
co-dads, what would you ask?
- Do y'all sleep in the same bed?
- What is the hardest
part being in a throuple?
- Do you ever vent to one
partner about the other?
(laughs)
(fierce music)
- What are you guys' names?
- I'm Mitch.
- I'm Ben.
- And Benjamin
- Being in a throuple, is that something
that happened to you
guys spontaneously or...?
- We met on a gay cruise,
there was 5,000 gay men.
Mitch and I had been talking about wanting
to be in throuple for a very long time.
In my mind, I never thought
it was gonna happen.
I was very skeptical,
so when I met Benjamin
I remember having a very
insightful conversation
and all the right
questions were being asked.
That experience to me was just reassuring
that this actually was
gonna possibly work.
- Are you all married?
- For Benjamin, the
third that joined last,
me and Mitch are both legally married.
- I never really believed in marriage,
so it didn't matter to me
like who got married to who.
Cuz I feel like marriage is just a label
and it's a legal protection.
- Do y'all sleep in the same bed?
- Yes, we have an Alaskan king bed
which is the size of like almost
two king beds put together.
- How sick.
- What is your favorite sexual position
that involves all three of you?
- We don't have sex.
(everyone laughing)
- It depends on which mood we're in.
- Is there like two bottoms?
- One top and two verse.
- Okay.
- Do all three of y'all have
to be present during sexy times?
- In the beginning, yes.
- But as our schedules evolved
it was like, alright,
if we're gonna get some
we gotta take what we
can get at this point.
- Fair.
- Who's better?
No one?
- We all have our off days.
Okay.
(laughs)
- Some, some of us overthink things.
- In terms of like cheating,
like what boundaries do
you all set for each other
and for your other partners as well?
- We are a closed triad,
so we we would be I guess Trinagamous.
- I think we have rules in place
that would also kind of
prevent that from happening.
You know, don't want
dates with other people,
don't have Grindr,
you're not gonna put
yourself in that situation.
- This one's a little spicy.
How would the throuple work
if one of you would want to break up
with another person in the
party, but not the third?
- She's starting drama.
- I'm just curious.
- Get a lawyer.
- Oh no!
(laughs)
- We would?
- Like, Ben and I have
been dating 17 years
and almost four of those
years have been with Benjamin
and we kind of had an agreement
that if something went wrong
in the throuple relationship
and the third like didn't
want to be there anymore
that we would still stay together.
But now that it's evolved into this
I don't know if one of us wanted out,
I think we'd all leave cuz we
kind of hold each other up.
- Do you ever vent to one
partner about the other?
(laughs)
Or is there a rule that y'all
have that restricts that?
- No, we definitely vent.
- Absolutely yes.
- Just like that scene from Mean Girls
where everybody's talking
to each other on the phone,
it's kind like that.
- But we have Nest cameras in the house
so if I'm gone, I know how to listen.
(everyone laughing)
- Is there ever any moments
where one feels left out?
- There was jealousy in the
beginning between those two.
Just saying.
(laughs)
- I feel like it was more the
feeling of being left out.
Like every time I was at work
I was like, "What are they doing?
"Why is he washing the sheets again?"
- "Why are you washing the sheets again?"
- In the chance that, you
know, there's an argument
or some kind of like, you know, issue
is one of y'all like
the preferred mediator
is like one of you guys
the counselor of the group,
like how does that work?
- So we all exchange roles.
- I will go to Mitch for different reasons
than I go to Benjamin for.
So if I need help with like, I don't know
advice with work or
finances or the business
I will go straight to Mitch
and if I need help with technical things
or my computer's crashing...
- Thanks.
(everyone laughs)
- If it's a serious issue, I think
we always come together and discuss it.
- There have been
moments where I go to one
to tell them not to tell the other
and they of course go to the other
and then it turns into a huge argument
that didn't have to be.
- It's a triad argument.
(laughs)
- I think I've learned my lesson.
- I'm just starting to
be in a throuple myself.
- Oh nice.
- And last night actually they,
two of them got into a fight
and I literally was standing
in the hallway going,
"What do I do?"
- You jump in girl.
(laughs)
- Well, I'm like, "Who do I go talk to?"
- Whatever they're arguing about,
you definitely need to make
sure that you don't take a side
without knowing the full story.
- I would just like to add that
when Benjamin first
came in of course Mitch
and I would have a lot of arguments
and it was actually very interesting
because he helped us
figure out a resolution
faster than we would've
done it just by ourselves.
- What is the hardest
part being in a throuple?
- They can both tell me
no and then I'm wrong.
(everyone laughs)
- That's the easiest
part of our relationship
when it's like, oh two people
say you're wrong, done.
- Yeah, it's like two of you won.
Anybody else?
- I would say juggling
expectations at first.
Normally you just have
to worry about like,
"Oh what does my partner expect from me?"
Doing it for two people,
you're just tracking
two sets of expectations.
- If you have a child, do
you worry it'll be hard
for all your three to bond with the baby?
- So we have a child.
- Oh!
- Surprise.
- She's almost six months old
- And we have two more
coming through surrogacy.
And I must say that so far the baby
like reacts equally to all of us.
So we're actually in the process
of all three of us being added
to the birth certificate of
Tegan, which is our daughter.
And we would be the second throuple
in the United States to be recognized
as legal parents of one child.
- Yes.
- Any of y'all have like
a concern about your child
not having a quote like
"traditional mother?"
- So when we started
the journey for adoption
it was a long time ago,
we started with an agency
then we moved to a private
adoption with an attorney
and our own website and the first thing
that our team said to us was like,
"The adoptive mom is just gonna be
"so excited about three dads."
And it did, we got so much hits
on our website and so many matches.
We never saw any pushback with that.
- But we also have a lot of friends
like really close friends that would play
a motherly figure if we needed to.
You know, we talked
about like when she goes
through puberty, like
what are we gonna do?
Like, you know, I freaked out
when I first had to change her diaper.
- Yeah, I was just like
interested to hear,
especially in this society
where things are still
way too labeled like that
and boxed up like that.
If that has been maybe like a hurdle
y'all have had to go through.
- Yeah I would I would just
maybe use an experience...
So when we first came out as gay,
Mitch and I as gay, we used
to get the question a lot
like also who's the woman
in the relationship?
You know who's the man
in the relationship.
And that, you know, at first you kind of
had to understand where the
question was coming from.
- Yeah.
- Because that's the only way
we're gonna educate someone.
But from us we don't look at it
one of us like you're the mother,
you're the father and I'm the nanny.
Like none of that like it's...
- You, the nanny.
(laughs)
- Mexican nanny.
- What would you give as advice
for someone who's possibly
looking into polyamory
or just also joining a throuple?
- I think you just have to be open.
There's so many different ways to love
than just being in a relationship
and it's very similar.
It's just we've been told by society
for so long that only two
people should be together.
- A lot of people go
in with a set of rules
and when they don't align
or they don't work out
the way you think they did,
they just kind of run away from it.
That's an opportunity for you to sit down
and really have a conversation
about why it didn't work.
How can we tweak them
so that it actually works the next time.
- Those rules are gonna adjust,
they're gonna change based on like
what your living situation is.
- I mean, cost of living
is so high, it helps.
(everyone laughs)
- Facts.
- Can I give y'all a hug?
- [Throuple] Yeah.
- So you want to meet?
- Yeah, I'd love to meet y'all.
- Hello.
- Look at the matching shirts.
- That's right,
- You guys are matching.
- I love your outfit.
- Oh, thank you.